tard dans la nuit l'homme qui filme ces
images sans une forte odeur de fumée
ils découvrent depuis sa fenêtre trois
voitures en flammes
l'une d'elles appartient à sa soeur en
tout une quinzaine de voitures a brûlé
dans la nuit sur différents lieux autour
du boulevard henri bazin et cette
situation n'est pas nouvelle
en juin les incendies se sont multipliés
et le maire a décidé d'instaurer un
couvre-feu pour les mineurs
celui ci a pris fin lundi et n'a pas été
reconduit aujourd'hui la mairie ne
souhaite pas lier ces différentes
affaires
mais demandent surtout plus de moyens il
est évident que malgré les efforts des
acteurs de terrain que ce soit au niveau
de la police nationale que ce soit au
niveau de la justice que ce soit au
niveau de la mairie il y à un défaut de
moyens mis à la disposition et il y à un
défaut de clarté sur l'engagement
politique de ce gouvernement pour
préserver la tranquillité publique dans
les quartiers notamment dans les
quartiers en difficulté des effectifs
supplémentaires déjà demandé en juillet
sans réponse
de son côté la police a ouvert une
enquête pour retrouver les auteurs de
ces incendies